Hey,
what's going on?
Is Bill Burns the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
December 8th,
2014.
What's going on everybody?
How are you?
Um,
AH,
Jesus Christ,
all freckles.
Oh,
freckles has been fucking smoke at too many cigars and the fucking booze.
I don't want,
I'm doing,
you know what it is.
I'm ready for my fucking year to be over.
I'm ready to be on a vacation.
I'm burned out.
I am burned out from
all the crap I've been doing.
I don't work this hard.
I'm a comedian.
I sit around on a couch all day.
I take up the Ukulele just killing a day waiting for my show at eight o'clock at
night.
So what I was supposed to be doing,
but uh,
you know,
you've got a couple of things going on.
I had to promote my special everybody.
For those of you,
uh,
who didn't hear,
I have my new stand up special just came out a Friday.
It's on Netflix exclusively.
It's exclusively on Netflix.
It's called,
I'm sorry you feel that way.
And,
um,
got to admit,
people really seem to be liking it.
Thank Christ.
Um,
I want to thank everybody,
you know,
Netflix,
new wave j Charisse for a directing it,
um,
giving me the special,
the look,
the went that I wanted.
Um,
and people seem to like it,
so that's all good.
It's all fucking good.
Um,
as far as you wondering,
well Wayne,
can I,
yeah.
Wait,
can I see guy buy it?
Um,
Netflix has it for a year.
One year from now when anybody who wanted to see it already has seen it,
then I'm allowed to sell it on DVD,
blue ray or whatever the fuck I want to do.
Uh,
you know,
you know the deal.
So,
uh,
that's when,
and that's when I'll,
I'll have it available.
That's just the deal.
That's just how it is,
you know,
considering,
uh,
the current climate on the Internet,
this is the way you have to do the deals because,
uh,
you know,
people fucking steal.
So somebody's willing to put the money up for this special,
what the fuck are you going to do?
Plus Netflix works great for me because I like to try to travel as far as I can
internationally speaking.
And uh,
you know,
Netflix seems to be getting more international as we go along.
So it's been,
it's really been a nice marriage between the two of us.
But seriously,
I got a ton of great feedback.
Um,
all my special and uh,
I feel it's my best work,
you know,
and now that I've said that you guys can be conscious and be,
we'll actually,
I saw you in premium blend in.
I felt,
uh,
the material combined with your fucking Valora shirt was much better.
Um,
the fuck did I wear on that?
I think I hit on it and we think it was a crushed velvet.
The fucking green button up shirt or something like that.
And black pants.
I can't remember.
It was one of those ones where the,
it became dated I think before the end of my set.
MMM.
But,
uh,
you know,
if he wants to,
to while you take a chance and it doesn't work up,
I basically look like a,
I'm in Robin Hoods.
Like if Robin Hood had an agent,
like that's how you would dress,
whatever.
Nobody gave me shit that night.
So everyone had watched was also guilty.
All right,
let's plow ahead here.
So anyway,
so I have to take my fucking laptop over to this place here in my,
uh,
my part of Los Angeles and I take it over there and the guy figures out what I
need is a,
I needed a new hard drive so he puts the new fucking hard drive in.
So this morning I go to,
you know,
okay,
download all the information,
I get all your questions and whatnot and then make my list of subjects that I
might talk about I might not talk about.
So I go to open up this fucking zip program APP.
I don't know what the fuck you call it.
It's one of the things we can actually write.
You know,
you can type some shit on it,
save it later,
and then like a document.
And I opened the fucking thing up and immediately it's just steering me towards
this soundcloud Shit.
Yeah we can save it and then you can have it on all your devices that you know,
have you ever thought about how fucking dumb you are if you're using soundcloud?
I'm not even talking about is convenience the fact that you're just giving
access to your God damn life to chill took God knows hoe.
You know what and then you're going to sit around and yeah
I believe somebody stole my identity.
Yeah.
A picture of my dick end up on the fuck.
That's like what are you doing?
Don't give people access to your photos and your files and all of that shit
because it's some fucking little kid mentality.
Well what if I lose them?
What do you got to fucking balloon tied around your wrist as what you got the
backup hard drive for.
Put them on there and once a week just fucking send a few over there and then if
something catastrophic happens to your laptop,
you can still have 98% of your shit you're going to survive.
So having said that,
cause anybody know how to disable that fucking Goddamn cloud.
Yeah.
Fucking Weirdo man fucking creep.
That's just like some nerd.
Like if you looked over and there's just some nerds standing in your window with
his black frame glasses,
trying to look at all your pictures joint to see,
uh,
what the fuck you're writing about.
Trying to see what websites you're on.
The whole thing is fucking creepy.
You know,
it's really creeping me out.
Is somebody recently is trying to suggest that the camera that's on your fucking
laptop is on all the time and potentially somebody could be watching you or it's
recording you or whatever.
Um,
what the fuck are they going to save all of that.
You know what I mean?
Although it does kind of freak me out.
Um,
I just,
I just had a bad week with the technology.
Everybody,
I um,
I am so fucking anti all of this shit and I know is,
I just feel like it's convenient as it makes your life.
Yeah.
Yes.
The,
the amount of fucking money it costs and shit crashing and then you've got to
upload it.
And then try to figure out how to use the new shit and then then just,
just more and more trying to figure out just spy on you the fucking spine or you
for whatever reason to try to sell you more toothpaste or to just make sure they
got enough dirt on anybody who ever decides to run for political office for the
rest of fucking time.
Do you realize right now that the next president,
right,
not the next president was some precedent in the future.
Say some president in 2040 or whatever right now is probably getting videotaped,
jerking off to something,
right,
and they're going to have all of that fucking information.
All the fucking creepy shit you did.
All your weird little thoughts.
Okay?
All your insecurities,
all every fucking thing they need to know about you to keep you in line.
I know everybody thinks this is like paranoid thought.
I know it's not this word.
J Edgar.
You know how much j Edgar Hoover would fucking love the cloud.
That fucking Weirdo used to sit there going around Washington trying to just
have dirt on everybody
so you can walk up and talk to you and just know shit about you,
who you will fucking,
what you were doing if you were secretly gay or anything.
And he probably sat there talking to you.
Right.
The weird look on his face.
You'd be like,
this guy's just giving me the creeps.
Why is he,
why is this guy giving me the fucking creeps?
It's cause he knows about your life and he's so excited about it.
He's probably fuck his fucking Dick is probably at half mast as he's talking to
you.
You know
Jay Edgar?
Okay.
Yeah.
And then they tried to say that deck guy who actually was a,
he used to walk around in a dress all day.
Yeah.
I don't understand that.
I don't understand why you would want to walk around in a fucking dress as a man
or a woman.
Not really the dress.
I can understand the dress.
It's like having a bathroom that doesn't open.
Right.
Where are one of those fucking things?
You know,
I haven't had a smock.
I just don't get the shoes.
Why the fuck would you want to wear?
I mean,
they look good.
They look good when the ladies prints around and,
but what the fuck would you,
why,
why anybody in their right fucking mind would want to walk around and your tippy
toes,
the whole God Day fucking up your back is beyond me.
And you would think that if you're a dude,
you're like,
oh good.
I don't have to wear that shit to go out of your way to actually wear it.
Why would you do that to yourself?
You know why I got to kill it?
Dress up like a woman,
but wear some flats.
J Edgar,
you know,
you're going to fucking slip a disc.
You know,
you're not exactly in shape.
Okay.
Um,
anyways,
this is the Monday morning podcast.
Um,
I don't know what the fuck I'm doing with my life.
I'm so fucking busy.
I got one more acting Gig here was shooting the Fx FX pilot this week.
I'm doing it this week with the always sunny guys.
Um,
and I wrap next week on Wednesday.
All right.
I wrap next week,
Wednesday when I wrapped next Wednesday,
actually Tuesday nights.
So Wednesdays can be my first just back to being a comedian again.
All right.
Back to my fucking playing drums,
back to my,
uh,
well,
whatever the fuck else I used to do.
Go on hikes with my dog.
I cannot fucking wait and I got two,
three weeks where I'm just going to chill out and buy,
chill out.
I mean probably do stand up 80% of the nights cause I got to come up with the
new act cause I got my big,
my big tours coming up of uh,
Australia,
New Zealand and uh,
parts of Asia,
Singapore,
Hong Kong.
Um,
Saigon did not work out.
Uh,
we're going to have to do that on the next one,
but um,
and then I'm going to some fucking place in India.
Okay.
I don't know what it is.
I think it used,
it's the place that used to be called Bombay.
Let me look it up.
I think it's there.
I shouldn't be saying that shit.
Okay.
Let's see.
Bombay,
India.
Let's see what it says here.
Yeah.
Mumbai.
I think that's where I'm going.
Jesus Christ will do these fucking pictures.
Feast of famine.
Um,
okay.
Yeah,
so I'm going to be doing that.
I'm actually a little creeped out to be flying around,
uh,
Asia and that type of shit.
Just cause,
uh,
I don't know,
reading up on fucking aviation and that type of thing.
Just I'm,
I'm just hoping I have the whatever plane I'm on.
The copilot when he sees we're running out of gas,
doesn't give a fuck about embarrassing the captain and says,
Hey dude,
I'm not trying to be a dick here.
I'm not trying to get out of a out of line,
but uh,
we're gonna fucking be on the ground at 10 minutes,
unless you fucking pulled over at a station.
We're running out of gas over here.
Look,
I'm not even looking at you and might even looking at you captain.
Not Trying to disrespect your authority or suggest that you're fucking up right
now,
but you kind of fucking up right now.
All right.
I,
I'm,
I'm nervous about that.
Other than that,
that and getting chained in Singapore,
I've been told that you can just kind of do whatever you want on stage.
It just doesn't make sense to me that if I'm in a fucking country that you can
get arrested for spitting gum on the sidewalk.
That I can actually go on stage and talk the way that I want to talk.
I don't know about that.
Oh,
Billy Budd cheeks is going to find out though.
No,
I'm really looking forward to it.
Um,
it always,
uh,
you know,
it's always cool.
I'm,
I'm hoping to actually be able to hang out with the locals,
drink a couple of beers,
shoot the shit here.
What the fuck they have to say,
meet some comics abroad,
Yadda,
Yadda.
See what the fuck goes on over there.
That's going to start up a,
I don't even know.
Why don't I go to my own website and figure it out for you.
I actually did yesterday.
I did four hours of phone or right in the middle of the football,
so I missed a ton of football,
but I have to promote these,
uh,
I got to promote these shows and a call some places in New Zealand and
Australia.
Dude,
Australians are fucking hilarious.
I'm calling them up and almost every reporter was going,
um,
so you're touring all of Australia?
And I'm like,
yeah,
pretty much going across it and just about every,
uh,
okay.
Every major city except that one city that begins with an,
with an a that I'm getting a bunch of shit for,
for not going to add a lay or whatever the hell it's called.
Um,
it just didn't work out.
But anyways,
they all had the exact same question.
They would just go and like,
yeah,
I see you know yet.
Okay,
you're torn over here.
Uh,
why kept asking me why?
And I was like,
I dunno.
Kind of seem like,
why?
Why not?
Yeah.
Like why wouldn't I?
They've,
I don't know.
They're like Tevya read up on anything that's going on down here.
Do you,
do you know what's going on in the news?
And I'm like,
no.
Yes,
because your act seems really American.
I'm fucking American.
It's going to be fine.
Stop getting in my fucking head.
I went to Melbourne and I've been to Sydney and it went fine.
Yeah,
the fuck am I supposed to read up on wombats
just going down there talking about my life.
I guess it's going to be hot as fucking bulls when I get there.
My first one is January 27th I'm going to be at a in Perth,
Australia and uh,
yeah,
I guess it's going to be a could get upwards of 40 degrees Celsius.
Now for you,
those of you in the land of America is the,
is the easiest way to learn Celsius.
All right.
Water freezes at zero Celsius and boils at 100 degrees Celsius.
It's really simple.
All right,
so you know water boils at,
what was it,
212 degrees or some shit like that.
So all right,
so a hundred Celsius is two 12 that means 50 Celsius is like bought about 106
degrees.
You just do it that way.
You just keep cutting in and half.
He can roughly guess whatever the fuck it is.
So they said it gets up to about 40 Celsius.
So they're talking over a hundred fucking degrees.
Oh,
freckles is,
I wasn't counting on that.
I thought it was going to be nice and ball me cause I've,
I've been there in October and um,
it was a little bit chilly sort of fall type of weather and uh,
I guess they were coming out of their way to,
um,
I don't know.
But I'm looking forward to going to Perth and going to a bond.
Scott is very there for my favorite band ever.
ACDC.
So I'm gonna go pay my respects there.
They've got a statue of him there.
I'm going to walk around Perth for a day or so,
get acclimated to,
uh,
you know,
the time over there,
which is fucking brutal.
That would actually be the furthest.
Okay.
Oh No,
no.
Actually it wouldn't be,
that would actually be a better time zone for me.
Right.
Cause Sydney and Melbourne are further to the international dateline that's
closer to it.
So I'm actually moving farther away.
Sex.
You pick up a couple of hours.
Yes,
it's bad.
I'm sorry.
Doing the math there and then,
okay.
So on January 27th,
I'll be at the Perth Convention and Exhibition Center on the 29th,
I'll be in Melbourne,
uh,
art center fucking thing.
January 31st I'm in Brisbane,
Brisbane,
however the fuck you say at Brisbane City Hall on February 1st I got two shows
at the Sydney Opera House.
And then February 3rd,
I'm in New Zealand,
February,
Auckland,
Auckland town hall.
And then I'm doing the Opera House in Wellington,
New Zealand.
So,
um,
you know,
I've heard nothing but great things about New Zealand too,
unless you go to Australia and then they always make fun of them,
but it's just like you're just doing that because you got nobody else to make
fun of down there.
It's the closest fucking country right there,
right there.
So you get to act like all the fucking Yahoo's live in New Zealand.
You know,
I've driven a little bit of Australia.
I drove from fucking Melbourne over to the,
uh,
the fucking 12 apostles,
whatever the hell they were.
And,
uh,
you know,
it got a little hairy there as we were driving around you and sell him saying,
you get out there,
there's a lot of surfers and that type of shit.
But I mean,
you know,
I dunno.
Australis fucking insane.
Do you realize like the top 10 most poisonous snakes on the planet are all in
fucking Australia?
Every last fucking one of them.
Like the inland Taipan has like enough venom.
Okay.
I mean,
it would fuck it.
Just drop a God damn elephant,
right?
It bite the elephant.
And the elephant would be like,
oh,
what the fuck was that?
And then just Bam down on the ground,
fucking over.
And then that thing would dislocate it's jaws and it could swallow that elephant
whole,
I'm fucking with you.
He couldn't,
but it could fuck it up,
kill it.
And I evidently,
the reason why they have that much venom is because food is so scarce.
So they have to be,
even if they just wing it,
you know what I mean?
It'd be like a sniper shot you with a bazooka and just sort of grazed yet.
That would be it for you.
You'd be done.
You'd be finished.
So,
uh,
I'll be wearing boots the whole time.
I'm over there.
Okay.
I'm going to watch them thigh high Timberland's snake proof shit.
Um,
I don't know and I'm sure all the locals would be,
yeah.
Actually might dare actually fucking scared of you would have I don't give a
fuck.
Okay.
I don't give a fuck.
So,
uh,
and I'm,
I'm,
I'm actually going to travel really,
really,
really light.
Okay.
So for all you can see,
we're already going to give me shit going.
Bill,
you wore the same two shirts,
the whole fucking tour.
That's right.
I did.
All right.
Jim Morrison wore those smelly brown leather pants for an entire fucking tour.
I can't go with it.
With two shirts.
Old Billy two shirts
once you are two shirt,
red fish,
blue fish.
That's what the fuck I'm doing.
I'm going to have two pairs of pants,
two shirts,
and then I'm dressing like I'm on the Sopranos when I'm on a plane,
which means I'm wearing a little fucking track suit and that's it.
I'm going to have my fucking toilet trash with me.
Okay.
And I am not bringing,
yeah,
I'm not checking any fucking bags.
Okay.
But here's the problem.
I'm traveling with my lady
and you know how women travel,
you know they fucking,
yeah,
they fucking,
they bring a lot of shit.
Why women be bringing all that shit?
Sorry,
I don't want it to early nineties def jam now.
Um,
all right,
let's get to the inbox here.
What do we got here?
Let's,
let's get to some live reads for this week.
Oh my goodness.
Everybody.
Hey,
by the way,
I've actually figured out that I am dyslexic a little bit.
I'm not like really bad,
but I've really started to pay attention to it and the way words get jumbled up
as I'm fucking reading them.
And then I look at a word and I think it says life,
but it's actually file.
Okay.
It's not like the bill,
like a debilitating kind of fucking thing.
But I got a little adult,
you know,
you know a little bit.
A little bit.
All right,
man.
Great attention.
Grill masters.
The holiday season.
There is only this holiday season.
There is only one gift that is an absolute must have.
It's the mad gray gray,
gray,
gray.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
What's the mayor?
Great.
You ask,
I'm so psyched you PR.
I pretended you just asked that cause I got information on what it is.
A man's man grades are American made Mirka high quality hundred percent cast
iron grill grades that sit right on top of your existing grill grates just
holding down right?
Like if they were a gay couple,
the man great would be on top.
You understand what I'm saying?
Waiting at eight pounds of pace,
man.
Great.
Since your juicy tender meat with no flare ups and a perfect smear marks,
sear marks or every time I think I finally found the accent to make this copy.
Interesting man.
Greats patented design,
deliver stack gas quality flavor right at home.
Take advantage of the Mona Mona podcast,
holiday season special and get 33% off your entire order.
Also for a limited time for,
I'm going to get even more southern Fazio.
Also for a limited tab,
all the three months you can order three man greats.
Wait also for a limited time for every three men.
Great.
You already,
you get fourth man,
great for free.
Can you imagine that?
Imagine every time you are three carburetors,
you're going another one.
She had a bunch of car you for fucking yard.
Just head over to my and great.com and enter my coupon code bur beat are are at
checkout bullet points,
hundred percent make it made in America.
She had cast iron 33% off your order when you were a you enter but you are are
at checkout or three man.
Great.
You get the fourth one.
Free Migraines got to me a great.com and enter my coupon Kolbe,
B u r r checkout.
You know what?
It makes a great gift for dad and also a great blunt object if you got a fucking
intruder.
Alright.
Draft Kings,
draftkings.com million is a B and made all seasonLong@draftkings.com America's
favorite one week fantasy football site one week fantasy means no more seasoned
law commitments play whenever you want.
God an injured player,
no problem.
At draftkings.com it's like a new season every week so you're never stuck with
the same players.
Pick your team in minutes and you could be on your way to winning huge cash
cash,
cash this season.
One listener turned 10 bucks into five grand and you know what he did?
He probably went out and blew four grand on a bunch of bs and then realize that
five grand,
he probably was 2,500 after taxes.
Another turn $2 in a 10 grand.
Wait,
how do you turn 10 bucks into five grand and then another guy $2 into 10 grand?
He must've fucked.
He must have bet Tampa Bay and a new millionaire has been crowned nearly every
week this season@draftkings.com you could be next.
Imagine winning $1 million,
500 grand of the taxes in one day.
Just playing fantasy football@draftkings.com called the action get free entry
and to,
they're a hundred thousand dollar fantasy football contest this week.
We're at first place.
Takes home 10 grant.
Had to draft kings.com now and enter the Promo Code wide a fuck.
Do they keep saying cracked?
How come I keep getting other people's God damn copy here?
Yeah,
and all these crack people are,
but they're gonna owe me some money.
draftkings.com bigger events,
bigger winnings,
bigger millionaires enter cracked for whatever fucking reason for entry
now@draftkings.com draftkings.com that's draft kings.com all right,
what about I?
You got live against the fucking three left.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
I apologize people.
All right.
He voice.
Yeah,
evidently I love the flexibility that owning my own business provides.
Look at me,
everyone.
I've created an empire with this show.
Why are they putting words in my mouth?
But when it comes to handling your business calls,
you're stuck with a challenge.
Either hire a full time receptionist,
right?
Walking around in their little skirt,
threatening to ruin your marriage or handle all your calls yourself.
It's a lose lose unless you talked to your deck.
That's why I love he voice.
They will set,
they will set your business up with a toll free number or a local number.
Uh,
when customers called,
they're greeted professionally by a virtual receptionist that will route all of
your calls to wherever you are.
There's even a dial by name directory.
You know what's going to happen.
You're going to sound like a fortune 500 company and more importantly,
you're never gonna miss an important call again.
All for under 13 bucks a month.
Right now for a limited time,
my listeners can try he voice for free for 60 days.
Oh yeah.
Seriously.
My listeners get an extended 60 day trial test drive to test drive this amazing
business tool.
That's right.
Stop asking me if it's right.
60 days.
Just for our listeners,
go to [inaudible] dot com slash bill B I l l now to sign up,
set up your ear voice 60 day extended free trial now at [inaudible] dot com
slash [inaudible] that's [inaudible] dot com slash bill.
Okay.
All right,
here we go.
Let me get back to the Goddamn questions here for this week.
Um,
okay.
What else did I want to talk about too?
That was a huge fire last night.
He went downtown La and it was just,
I'm pretty sure it's this apartment complex that I have been driving by.
Um,
drove by it a lot this year.
I mean those of you who watched that Seinfeld thing,
you guys know that I learned how to fly a helicopter this year.
And,
uh,
so I,
I would get up early in the morning and as I was driving down,
you know,
for my lessons,
um,
okay.
I would fucking drive by this apartment building that was going up in like two
seconds,
you know?
And as I'm sitting there getting construction downstairs and that's taken off
fucking goddamn year and I'm watching this thing just flying up in granted they
got fucking a hundred person crew or whatever.
MMM.
This thing burned to the goddamn ground and these firefighters talking about it
was hilarious.
Was saying how big the fire was,
was saying that they actually call it like this was a career fire.
Yeah.
You know,
like a quarterback had a career day,
you know,
go in 35 or 38 for 460 he had a career day.
These firefighters have like a career fire.
How fucking great and expression that is that are there any fire fighters who
listened to this?
I want to hear about your career fire.
You know,
I want to use some from some firefighters.
Okay.
I want to hear what's the most fucked up thing you you've seen in a fire.
I don't mean anything disgusting about death.
I mean afterwards as you're going through the fucking rubble,
trying to find like what caused the fire.
Have you ever just found like a safe at the bottom of it and nobody's claiming
it?
You know,
and then you try to get the fat fuck from the firehouse.
The Guy who makes the Chili to come over there and try to pick it up and put it
in the back of your fucking dodge Ram.
You know,
it sounds like a fucking movie with Billy Bob Thornton.
All right?
And we don't tell anybody.
Okay.
Ends up being some fucking,
come on,
man.
He can't tell me every once in a while
you went in there,
your risk,
your life.
I mean,
fucking burn into deaths.
Gotta be one of the worst deaths ever.
And you face that every fucking day.
You can't tell me that when you're rummaging through that you find you don't
find a couple of trinkets and be like,
you know what?
I earned this.
Stick it in the front fucking lapel pocket of,
you're a heavy duty rubber rain coat there.
Does that made out of rubber?
Right.
It would melt.
I Dunno.
I want to hear some fire stories,
but I want to hear about people getting burned up.
I don't wanna hear about that shit,
but I just like,
uh,
you know,
is,
is the logo,
are you the low guy on the totem pole as a firefighter where after the big boys
put the fire out?
Yeah.
The guys got to sit there pissing on it for like the next three days.
Just standing up there.
Okay.
Going back and fuss gotta be the shittiest job ever.
There's no fucking excitement whatsoever.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
you know,
you've got the,
he got the fucking maniac who writes the book.
He gets to drink whiskey,
be suicidal and fuck bitches.
Right then.
Then you've got the guys,
the proof reader in the end.
Got To make sure the past part is both.
There's that put the pluck an adverb,
whatever the fuck they do.
Yeah.
That's what,
that's what that guy is.
That guy's the firefighter equivalent of like a proof reader,
you know,
or that guy in the locker room who picks up all the towels after all the
players,
fucking rub the balls with them.
That's what that is.
That has to be,
there's no way.
There's no way you're in the starting lineup at your fucking firehouse and you
got to do that shit.
You're not doing that.
Yeah,
they wouldn't notice the flavor.
Alright,
come on.
Do you guys break that guy's balls when he's up there?
Hey,
make sure you spray over there.
I think I saw a fucking spark it to,
um,
anyways.
All right,
let's talk a sports.
You know what?
I watched very little football this week because I was wrapping up watching a,
I was,
I was binge watching is the children's sales that,
uh,
that show,
the killing.
Um,
I've watched the first two seasons about a year ago and I started to watch
season three a,
the first episode.
I don't know what happened.
I just got busy.
And what was cool is a,
during the time it took many jumped back on,
um,
seasons,
not a season four was shot and was uploaded.
So I got to watch the whole series.
So I,
uh,
you know,
season four only had like seven episodes,
so I just Kinda was blowing through those sinks.
So I missed a lot of games.
I did watch the Seahawks Eagles game and uh,
Oh my God,
fucking Paul Versey is so God damn funny,
man.
Okay.
Years ago,
right.
He said that,
um,
he said that,
you know,
after three games and he said,
Mark Sanchez was a star.
All right.
And I said,
Paul,
it's been three fucking games.
He's a rookie.
You don't think he's going to have that for game,
you know,
four picks in a game that picked six or whatever.
He's a rookie.
Blahblahblahblahblah classic Paul Versey,
he sees a guy out of the gate playing well and then goes,
this guy's going to be the greatest fucking ever.
Right.
Um,
so anyways,
so the guy,
you know,
he feet,
it didn't work out for him.
I'm not saying,
and I'm going to pay him in saying that the guy is a,
uh,
a bad quarterback.
Yes.
He's not a bad fucking quarterback but,
but like,
you know,
I mean people will act in like you had to call them up Sanchez,
like he was a franchise quarterback.
Right.
So anyways,
um,
so yesterday he's Qb and for the eagles and he's having a,
he's having a good game and fucking Versie rights end.
He finally admitted that he was wrong about Sanchez.
So now this Eagle's game,
he's playing good against Seattle and he said,
he goes,
dude,
I may have been right about Sanchez dude can ball,
maybe not a star,
but good for sure.
It's just like,
you see how he tries to warm out of it?
He goes,
I may have been right when,
when you said the guy was a star Sanchez and all that,
and then he goes,
maybe not a star,
but good for sure.
And it's just like,
dude,
that's not what you said.
I never said Sanchez wasn't a,
it wasn't a good quarterback.
So of course they were in Becky,
you're the worst.
You said he was a star.
All right.
I don't want to fucking get involved in this.
We mean verse,
he went round and round because you know I did this weekend.
I actually test drove some fucking Kaz and I took out that Mercedes Benz station
wagon,
AMG,
the biggest fucking
on the planet.
Dude,
this car was the shit.
I'm going to upload some video,
right?
The car,
like when you go to park the fucking car,
the steering wheel moves itself like it has sensors all around the car.
So you'll put it in reverse and it cuts the wheel automatically and gets you to
a certain point and you just control the pedals,
the gas to the brake,
and then you put it in drive and then it turns it the other way.
You got to see this fucking,
uh,
okay.
This fucking video.
I went over there with a buddy of mine and a test drove a couple of fucking cars
do this car was so fucking bad ass.
I'm driving down the hill and there was this fucking smoke shelf as they say on
Barstool Sports,
walking this dog.
And the last time I drove and I drove by in a car and a woman locked eyes with
me the entire fucking way before looking away and horror.
I can't even remember.
I think I was in my college years.
I fucking came down in a fucking station wagon.
She should be running the other way.
This car was so fucking bad ass looking.
She fucking locked eyes with me.
The whole,
I couldn't believe it.
It's like I went back in time.
MMM.
Took out one of those in and I took a different one that was like a four door
coupe and a dude.
That's the fucking car that is the car because that is like,
it's a supercar and you can put a bunch of people in it.
Either you get the sedan or you get the,
uh,
the station wagon.
And Paul Versey just kept,
I kept telling Paul how fucking sick the car was and he just kept going at it.
It's just a station wagon.
I just can't get by it.
I was like,
Paul,
that's what makes it fucking cool.
It's the fact that it is a station wagon and you'd look like,
do you think the person's a nerd and that they got their groceries and a bunch
of pacifiers in there and then all of a sudden he fucking takes off from the
line in his job,
groceries and babies are flying out the back fucking window.
That's what makes it fucking cool.
And I just can't,
I can't get past that.
Eh,
it's a wagon.
I mean it's,
it's a fucking waste.
Like that's it right there.
Okay.
You got Yay.
You got no style.
Anybody can go out and like a Porsche.
Anybody can like a corvette.
Anybody can like a Ferrari there.
There's no thought process.
Okay.
You know,
that's why I like watching shows like gas monkey garage
right
fast and allow whatever the fuck is called.
Gas Monkey garage.
Oh,
I love watching that show.
Now when they take a fucking car that's known to be fast,
I like when they take a fucking,
you know,
two door fucking sedan.
Okay.
Like dead time.
They bought a Casey's fucking a 55 Ford and sold it to mark Cuban.
That fucking car was so god damn cool they did that and they didn't want a 1950s
Oldsmobile.
Like I don't know.
To me that that's,
I dunno,
those are those other cars,
right?
The Ferrari's and all that.
That's like going on stage as a comedian and telling a Dick joke,
it's a fucking layup.
You know,
people are going to laugh.
I know I don't,
I got a lot of German blood.
Me and what I love about Germans is,
what's funny to me about them is they really bad about getting along with other
people.
But you give those motherfuckers a station wagon and somehow that thing will go
zero to 60 in 3.6 seconds at dude,
it's a fucking race car.
You know,
station wagons usually had that seat in the back where people face the other
way.
This car doesn't have that.
That's how fast to try and get this thing to go because it's a weight issue.
So they got that thing the fuck out of there.
And um,
that is the first time I ever drove a car.
Both cars that I drove and they have a dual clutch.
And I never thought I would say this,
but it just eliminates,
like back in the day,
if you've got a sports car and it was an automatic,
you would the biggest fucking pussy,
the whole car was ruined.
You know what I mean?
Like if you bought a corvette and it was an automatic yeah,
you're just a Douche bag.
Like why would you do that?
The stick shift is so much faster.
You can slow down by downshifting as you're fucking dive in into the Goddamn
turns,
right.
Scaring the shit out of your passengers.
Right.
But now,
I mean I,
I didn't even understand the whole concept of it until like a week ago.
I started reading up on how that,
I was talking about like a week ago,
that whole dual clutch system,
basically this is how
fucking psychotic in a good way.
These guys are,
who designed these cars and I guess a dual clutch system has been around since
the fucking early eighties I just heard about it,
which is not surprising cause I'm a moron.
But basically,
you know when you're driving a car,
right?
You're going down the street and you're,
and you're hearing it going through the gears at Wham Bam,
right?
That little pot,
you know,
so it was like a lot.
When you're in your seat and exam,
you come off the seat where you're backing him up to seed,
my aim,
you're coming off the seat because the clutch is basically disengaging with the
engine and fuel and the engine still working like a motherfucker.
But for that split second,
when you push in the clutch and it's a neutral,
you're the,
the engine's working for nothing right now.
That little sliver of that little split second,
when you go to shift,
you're losing that torque from the engine.
So the dual clutch system eliminates you coming off.
You see by it puts the odd gears on one side of the training and the even on the
other,
and I don't know how to fuck it switches off the way it does,
but I was driving that car and I'm listening and going through the gears and I
never came off my seat and the guy says,
you can use the paddle shifters if you want,
but you'll never be able to shift faster than the dual clutch dude.
You just step on the gas and it's like,
man,
just fucking going through the gears.
It's fun.
It's so completely unnecessary to have when you're driving down the street,
it's so fucking unnecessary to have when you just drive it around civilians that
you gotta have one.
Um,
does that make any sense?
I am completely sold
on those cars and I'm a,
I'm glad I went shopping around and all of that type of shit.
So now I just got it.
I got to save up to get one,
which is why I'm touring all through Australia,
New Zealand,
India,
Asia before.
Dude,
I am,
I,
I'm so fucking psyched for that tour.
I am going to lay waste to that land down there.
I am so chomping at the fucking bit too to fucking do stand up right now.
And I got all these goddamn ideas that I want to work out.
Um,
dude,
I got to,
I,
I can't,
I don't know how to tell this story without giving away the joke that I'm doing,
but I'm gonna tell you why Joe Rogan is the greatest fucking dude ever.
Um,
I got this bit that I want to do and it adds like a physicality thing.
Like possibly even like a prat fall and a lot of standup comics,
whatever,
look at it like,
oh,
the pret full,
let's fucking hacky or whatever.
I'm just looking at it like,
wait a minute,
that's,
that's part of comedy,
man.
Like you gotta learn how to do that shit.
So I have this idea for a fucking joke that would possibly involve something
like that.
I'm just kind of playing with the,
and Rogan's going like,
dude,
what the comedy store?
And he's gone through it.
You get to,
you could totally do that.
He goes,
come over to Mike's House.
I'll show you how to do it.
I got the fucking,
I got,
you know,
he's,
he's got like an octagon in his goddamn garage,
dollar Mattson,
Shit.
He goes,
I'll show you how to do it in this fucking maniac.
Loves comedy so much.
She's such a good dude.
We're backstage at the comedy store and he's doing these fucking rolls from a
standing position onto the fucking floor and I'm just die.
I'm fucking laugh and go on this guy.
Like,
who the fuck else would do the
fucking four?
Might not even his own joke.
He showed me how to do,
how he goes easy.
You could just fucking do it like this.
It looks like you fall,
but you kind of rolling into it.
He did it so well.
It's like,
dude,
you want to do the fucking joke?
But uh,
anyway,
so the,
for my next special,
you see me flopping around on the fucking stage,
know that it's because Joe Rogan took the time to show me how to do that
backstage backstage at the comedy store.
And by the way,
it Rogan is back at the comedy store,
which is the greatest thing ever.
Uh,
they,
you know,
they had a little,
a little riff there and a right,
right.
As I moved to La.
And I remember when I first lived in La in the late nineties,
one of the highlights of going down to the comedy store,
uh,
was seeing Rogan,
you know,
back in the day.
So I have last night I was down there and actually I was late so I didn't get to
say what's up to him,
but I actually saw him on stage.
That's the first time I saw him in the,
uh,
the Oh,
are also called the original room,
um,
since the late nineties,
when I think I made a couple of trips in the two thousands to la,
but I just don't ever remember running into him.
So he was doing fear factor.
Um,
anyways.
What else else?
Yeah,
so I whored myself out this week,
uh,
promoting my special,
I did Conan O'brien this week and once again,
I always have a good time on that show.
Thank you to Conan and uh,
Andy and all those guys for a laughing.
When I say something funny and helping me out when it bombs and,
um,
I think that's a,
I think that's about all I got for this week.
Oh,
the Bruins.
Jesus Christ.
We had a rough fucking road trip.
That was a rough one,
you know.
Um,
we lost a couple of close ones to the ducks and the kings and them just got
fucking hammered by the San Jose sharks.
I don't know what the fuck.
I mean,
I actually went back and watched it,
but I uh,
it was two to nothing when I left to go do some spots and I came back and I just
saw,
I was like seven to four.
We lost,
we give up seven fucking goals and two periods.
But you know,
you always,
you have one of those every year,
you have a regular season game.
It just gets away from you.
Then,
uh,
we beat the coyotes a couple nights later,
so we went one and three on the road trips.
So we'll come back.
We got the Chicago Blackhawks.
I'll tell ya,
it doesn't get any easier.
We've got the Black Hawks at home,
I think the wild or something like that coming up.
That's another thing I'm looking forward to over the break.
I haven't skated since like September.
Um,
yeah,
I gotta get back into all my fucking hobbies and all that shit.
So anyways,
let's,
uh,
in the,
like I got to read some questions here because I have another busy fucking day
here.
All right.
Wife and labor,
a Billy Black and white face.
My wife and I watched your new special on Netflix last night and then at 6:00 AM
this morning,
her water broke coincidence.
Probably not.
She did not want to watch it because she was having contraction contractions and
was in pain and I don't think she laughed once.
I cackled like a maniac while she glared at me for enjoying myself so much.
I think the hour and 15 minutes of glaring caused her to go into labor two weeks
early.
Is that a thing?
Thanks for the entertainment and go fuck yourself.
Jesus Christ out.
Your wife's had pain and you're still sat there and watched it.
Why didn't you fucking a
bring it back into the bedroom,
give her a nice book and a whatever,
peanut butter,
banana sandwich,
whatever the hell she's craving.
Um,
I dunno why.
I hope you had a nice healthy baby boy or girl,
whatever he had.
And um,
I hope your wife hates you,
would not make,
but um,
for those of you haven't seen my,
my newest special,
yes we did.
We shot it in,
uh,
with the latest cameras you can have when we shot it in black and white.
I always wanted to do with special ed black and white because I just think it
looks fucking cool as shit.
And uh,
and also I planned to do a bunch of specials and uh,
you know,
each one to have like its own kind of unique look,
so just imagine I got it.
So,
you know,
some color wasn't a boom.
I got this black and white one.
I shoot this other one this way or that way or whatever.
Um,
I don't know.
I don't like HD,
the level of HD TV right now.
It's so fucking clear.
It doesn't look real.
It's like,
it looks like a tropical fish tank.
Half of these shows you sitting there watching a car chase and you waste,
you're like waiting for a clown fish to swim by the,
uh,
pass the screen.
I don't know.
I'm not in it.
I'm not into it.
I'm an old man.
Look at me.
I'm releasing fucking vinyl records and black and white specials.
I am regressing.
Okay.
All right.
Last weeks,
24 year old version version,
Virgin Bill.
I wanted to weigh in on the 24 year old virgin question.
What the female perspective.
Oh,
but I love when the women writing.
I always get it from the fellas.
This one's from a lady.
She said,
this kid is potentially sitting on a golden ticket if he plays it right.
There are girls that get really turned on by the idea of fucking a virgin,
myself included.
Is that true?
Okay.
Uh,
she said,
myself included when I was still in the game.
It's sweet when you don't know what you're doing.
Sina,
I never would have known that because as a guy you feel like there's that
pressure that you're supposed to lead and you're supposed to know what the fuck
you doing from the get go.
Um,
so anyways,
she goes on to say and sweet.
We'll get you laid.
Oh,
it's sweet when you don't know what you're doing and sweet,
we'll get you laid a will knock your fucking brains out because we take,
because we get to take charge and we want to give you a great time.
I've been with guys who think they know what they are doing and it was far worse
than fucking a virgin.
A few words of advice.
Don't act all greasy and pretend you know what's going on.
What is greasy mean?
Cool.
Is this for the Virgin?
Yeah.
Just yes.
Just saying fucking throw your cards on the table.
Stand there with the fucking rock card deck gone.
What's happening?
Um,
anyways,
she said that's not a fucking turn on.
When you act all greasy,
pretend what you're doing and it will reflect poorly on your abilities.
Also don't get to fucking wasted.
Yeah.
A little liquid.
Courage isn't a bad thing,
but too much booze and your system will make you sloppy.
And if you pick a decent enough girl for your first fuck,
she might tell her girlfriends,
but your buddies,
we'll never know.
Um,
p s bill got to see you in Ottawa and you fucking killed it.
Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself.
Jesus Christ.
It's fucking right there.
That's the fucking blunt force trauma.
Truth of it all.
Um,
I appreciate you being so God damn honest.
Okay.
You know,
is that the way women talk when we're not around?
You guys sounded like truckers to lodge mage.
All right.
Adoption and I'm not shitting on you either cause I know I sound like a trucker.
I don't sound like a trucker.
While I do is just add the southern accent because everybody knows every truck
is from down south.
Right?
Speaking it down south,
everybody.
Um,
I am going to be doing another fucking tour of the south,
the dirty south,
and we're going to get an extra dirty,
this town.
I'm telling you right now,
I'm putting it together.
All right.
We're not going to be doing the main fucking ones that I've done in the past and
Nashville.
Atlanta.
Fuck that.
All fucking day.
All right,
we're going to Talladega.
We're going to mobile,
Alabama.
We're going to go into Mississippi.
I want to,
I want to go into,
I'm going to Homina.
Homina I want to go to like fucking some of these off the beaten fucking path.
Southern ones.
Do A,
do a bus tour.
Um,
I'm gonna,
I'm putting the fucking team back together again.
Just like the blues brothers.
All right.
That's something else in 2015 that's going to happen.
We'll get in the fucking bus back.
We'll get Steve the bus driver.
All right.
Versie law head and the coach and that's it.
It's gonna happen again.
Um,
I'm actually right after I'm done with this fucking podcast.
I'm calling my agent.
I'm going to pick a God damn time.
We're going to,
we're going to put it together.
I love the fucking self.
I love it.
All right.
Adoption.
Serber just finished a new special.
Amazing.
As always.
Thank you very much.
I very much liked your bit about adoption and as someone who grew up in a
family,
oh,
as someone who grew up in a family through adoption,
it's my honest opinion that it's the best and most socially responsible things
someone can do.
My sister,
brother and myself were adopted by folks.
My folks after my dad made the choice back when he was a kid in the 70s and met
an adopted schoolmate who had been through some shit in Korea and express his
true gratitude for being able to live a completely new life.
My mom has made it clear that they could have had their own and it wasn't a
question of possibility,
pain or timing.
Uh,
my dad just always felt the need to do it.
I don't know where I'd be without people like my parents and adoption should
really be how our new generation in privileged countries like our own acquire
that children.
Though I understand acquiring children's sounds like the to do list for an
African dictator.
Either way.
Thanks for the thousands of last laughs.
I hope you and Nia find tremendous joy in whatever you decide to do.
Any kid would be fortunate for you guys to have?
Oh,
any kid would be fortunate to have you guys as a mom or a dad.
Ah,
what a fucking great guy.
Um,
I gotta be honest with you to do with the fucking world population problem the
way it is.
You know what I mean?
And then all the kids out there that,
uh,
for whatever reason,
you know,
I can't imagine over in,
uh,
Iraq,
how many kids don't have fucking mom's or dad's at this point,
through that fucking shit show over the last 10 years and he's time of war just,
just fucking pulls everybody apart.
Um,
and over here,
you know,
well,
I don't know if they allow,
do they allow husbands and wives in the United States military?
You both go over there?
I wouldn't think so.
They seem to not do that after that.
I think after they had that one,
uh,
that shipped,
it went down a World War II when there was like five brothers from the same
family.
We're all on the same ship and the thing got torpedoed.
And some poor parents lost all five of their kids.
Man fucking brutal.
I think a,
the u s military does try to avoid that.
So,
um,
okay.
No,
I,
I wouldn't have a problem with that.
I should probably do it.
I'm fucking 46 right then I talk about that in my act.
I need a headstand.
He's just fucking get,
we get 10 year old,
so I'll still be alive when he graduates college.
Um,
no,
I don't think there's anything wrong with it.
I think it's a great thing to do.
And also,
you know,
not only is it great for the kid,
it is great for,
I hate using the word society,
mankind in general because if you don't have any sort of parental guidance and
you're growing up in some sort of foster home,
you know,
it's just like,
you're just going to grow up,
you know,
with a bunch of other fucked up kids and you just end up doing what they're
doing.
Uh,
when the person could actually,
you know,
if you have parental guidance,
you go to school,
you get a good job,
you meet him,
you know,
give me a nice lady or whatever.
You get fucking married or what do you chill?
You're all fucking angry from your child and all that.
God knows what you go out and go do,
right?
Um,
yes.
You know what?
You reconvince me.
Alright?
Underrated.
Doing dishes at spouse's family at spouse's family event is underrated.
All right?
I was at my sister in law's graduation party and decided to help clean up by
doing the dishes.
I was able to skip out on boring in law conversations while picking up some
credit by offering to do the dishes on top of it all,
I was able to catch the Patriots packers game on the kitchen TV while everyone
else was having to having to make small talk.
Dude,
that's fucking genius.
Okay.
I hate small talk.
I can't stand going to those fucking parties do and I'm going to steal that.
Whoever,
man or woman,
whoever wrote this sin Hermaphrodite I don't know who the fuck you walk.
God bless you.
I got a nice crowd.
Uh,
I got a nice crowd going in the kitchen and most of the men at the event wanted
to see the game.
We are rooting for the Patriots to win.
So the lines would have the NFC north.
Next time you get a chance to volunteer to do some easy cleanup,
nonstop.
Thanks.
And an easy out from boring conversations.
Wow,
man.
I got to tell you,
that might be the best one in a while.
Okay.
That's,
that's god damn genius.
Oh,
musical mud dancing doc.
Um,
so when he wears,
what do we got here man?
Look at this 53 fucking minutes.
53 minutes in and I'm out of shit to talk about.
I'm,
I'm a little talked out people I have,
I apologize,
you know,
whoring myself out,
hyping this fucking special and uh,
doing the radio,
the radio,
God Damn Torah.
Let's,
you know,
this is what I'm going to do.
How many just going to select some right now from my email account.
Okay.
Where are we?
Here we go.
Okay,
Click here and I click here signing into my account.
Isn't this exciting?
I have no idea what these questions are.
Gonna be
B.
MMM
hmm.
Advice.
Been out of the game.
It's changed.
All right.
What do we see?
Oh my God,
this fucking emails long.
Oh fuck.
All right.
Hey Billy,
bad ass.
I got a situation here and I can't make heads of tails of where I'm at with this
girl.
A modern day Casanova such as yourself should be able to figure out how to read
this girl.
Read this girl and it
vies me as the next as of the next step to take a,
if there is one.
So here's my problem.
Your problem is fucking spelling and punctuation so far,
my friend.
So here's my problem.
I'm 24 years old and was in a relationship with a girl for five years from the
ages of 14 to 19 when an ended,
it was drawn out and she strung me along until she was comfortable enough with
their next guy to cut it off for good.
Yeah,
that's what you're doing.
You're young.
I wouldn't take it personal.
She's only fucking 19.
She doesn't know how to get out of a relationship.
Do you,
you know,
you guys started dating at 14.
Um,
anyways,
well she goes,
well I live in a small town and the guy she went to was a little sissy girl Jean
where and Piss in Ah,
z.
Z.
Okay.
Ah,
Jesus Christ to Oh right.
I don't know.
I'm not gonna read the dude.
You sound like a fucking bully.
I know,
right?
You know what?
You're mad at him.
All right.
I'm going to give he Jesus Christ,
Dude.
Okay.
Thank God I pulled up on that one.
I would add to make an apology.
Um,
okay.
They can't take an ass whooping without calling the cops.
Okay?
Jesus Christ.
I to give her advice.
Let's just read this to hear of fucked up.
This guy is,
by the way,
big reason why I country is our country.
The reason why I country is going to hell in a handbasket.
It's cause the guys like this I get cause they can't take an ass kicking without
calling the cops.
All right?
This guy's old school.
Uh,
nobody is getting their ass beat anymore because of cop calling.
Ah,
Jesus,
which is salt is practically a prison sentence right away.
I digress dude.
You're a fucking mouth breathing moron.
Good Lord.
I'm actually ha,
um,
happy that she's fucking away from you.
See,
this is why we tried to screen these.
Goddamn.
Thanks.
Okay.
All right.
Where are
we?
Where are we?
Come on.
Somebody asked for if
men's room studio tour,
it's Cetera.
All right,
let's see what this one is.
High Bill.
Let's hope this one doesn't have a homophobic shit all over it.
All right.
Hi Belt.
I heard your podcast yesterday.
I was dying laughing when you talked about the men's rooms and all the smelly
shenanigans that happen in there.
I'm a woman who's never been in a men's public restroom,
so that was a shockingly funny revelation.
My husband never tells me it's discussing in there.
Perhaps he,
he's used to it.
Oh,
I mean it's a public restroom.
I,
by the way,
I've been in funny of ladies rooms.
Um,
I shouldn't say plenty.
I don't mean to say it that way.
I've been in there cause I used to be a busboy at a restaurant in,
in the morning.
I came in and I had to clean up both bathrooms and I was not surprised at how
filthy the men's room was.
But the fucking ladies room,
first of all,
this fucking toilet paper all over the place.
I don't know what's going on in the,
I think because they have to sit down to pee.
They just build the nest.
I have no idea.
And I'll spare you the fucking details.
All right.
But it looks like,
you know,
okay,
just imagine a ticker tape parade
combined with bodily fluids.
That's disgusting.
I'm sorry,
but that's what it looked like.
He goes,
on the other hand,
the woman's restrooms are quite the opposite.
God forbid you make a sound in there.
It's like an unspoken rule that women can't fart loudly installs.
If you asked me,
this is so unfair that we ladies have to hold it in.
Well you guys are doing it to yourself.
That's the lady's room.
Please don't blame the guys for that one.
Well,
you know,
in society it's not acceptable for us to Fart in public.
If a guy does it.
It's funny.
Oh,
fucking grow a Dick.
Okay.
Stop playing the goddamn victim.
All right,
let one rip and have you dressed.
Fly up like Marilyn Monroe.
I don't give a fuck.
Anyways,
I had the privilege to use the woman's restroom and south in the South Korea
airport and each Saul had a device that lets you play classical music or nature
sounds to mass the prostate area.
Trumpet blasting.
That's about to shoot out of my dainty,
but it was the best bathroom trip of my life.
Any who,
I don't know if you got my email months before my offer still stands.
You're welcome.
Oh,
to stop by our animation studio of Jesus Christ.
I was getting nervous,
sir.
Um,
oh.
All right.
Okay,
cool.
All right,
why don't we go here?
Where do we go?
Um,
do I dare to read?
I'm sorry you feel that way.
Feedback.
I got one more minute to do here.
Loved every minute of it man.
Like the black and white.
Absolutely.
Awesome.
Special.
Keep coming.
Police.
I'll,
that's awesome.
That's awesome.
I can't tell you guys how sack dam that you guys liked this,
this special.
Um,
and for those of you who are wondering why we shot it the way we do is because I
love standup comedy and I just feel like it should be shot like a movie.
You know what I mean?
Like standup comedy has this weird sort of thing where it has this a ton of
respect where people like,
dude,
I don't know how you get up there.
I could never do that.
Blah,
blah,
blah.
Yet it's also looked at like you're the guy with the lampshade on your head.
And I'll never forget when I did a half hour for comedy central,
I know I've told this story before and they did the promos for it and they
basically shot you sitting on a stool sorta making weird faces at the camera.
At least that's what they were asking you to do,
asking you to do.
And uh,
they just played this trumpet,
like the Promo.
It's like,
you know,
Bill Burrs,
half hour special.
And they just had me sitting there like shrugging my shoulders,
like,
Hey,
this is my half hour special and this trumpet was playing in the background,
went
bad,
bad
with a gun.
I remember watching it on who's sitting at home.
This is my first half hour special.
I was all excited and that fucking muted trumpet came.
It sounded like it was heckling me.
Okay.
Like that's the soundtrack to what the fuck I just did.
You know what I mean?
I just,
I don't know.
I don't fucking know.
But that's the greatest thing about this age of specialist is that Comedians
have so much control that you can actually shoot the fucking thing the way you
want to.
Um,
which we did.
And um,
that is all,
that is the podcast for this week.
Everybody.
I know I only did an hour this week.
I,
uh,
I just let me get through this next fucking acting Gig and then,
I'll be back.
Slap on my fucking gums again next week.
Uh,
come back a little stronger.
All right,
that's it.
Go fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you next week.
Oh,
I didn't even bring it up to patriots,
beat the fucking chair.
Um,
look to be a great game.
I was actually punching up this fucking script so I've yet to watch the game.
And um,
I did see that play that,
you know,
we intercepted it and brought it back and there was that great hit and you know,
those guys,
they got up just because somebody gets fucking laid out now it doesn't mean it
was like helmet to helmet.
That was like a great hit.
Um,
but I actually,
I do like,
you know,
as much as everybody's saying that the NFL,
oh it's,
you know,
the turning into this pussy league,
I liked that there isn't helmet to helmet hits.
I liked it.
They're trying to get that out of the game.
Cause I gotta be honest with you,
you know,
if you're younger I can see why you don't like it because you haven't seen any
of the guys that you liked when you were a kid.
Be 50,
60 years old and you know,
dealing with the effects of it.
Like,
you know,
the latest one,
the latest ones that shocked me was Tony doors set the great Tony Doors,
sat watching him struggle with like,
you know,
anger issues and all that type of thing due to the,
the hits he took in his career.
Uh,
I like that they having them lead with the shoulder and even then,
I mean you still,
your head can snap back.
It's,
it's always going to be a violent game.
But I think it's great that they are getting it out of there cause it's still a
fucking awesome game.
I don't think that guys have to be like suffering the way these players are
suffering for it to still be a great game.
So I,
I don't have a problem with it.
Having said all that,
that I,
that was a bullshit call that was a fucking hell of a play in a touchdown.
And uh,
I was nervous about that game cause I respect the chargers and fucking Philip
Rivers.
Um,
so anyways,
I don't know what to tell you.
A patriots attended three tied with the Broncos.
Thank God we beat them.
So we are a provider.
We,
when we,
when the rest of the way out or the Broncos lose one,
we will have home field advantage once again.
And uh,
we're looking good but I don't know man.
I still think the Broncos would be tough to beat them twice to be tough to beat
the colts twice.
Be Tough to beat the charges twice.
It just is.
I don't by any means think that it will be,
you know,
all of these paths.
Fans like dough,
we're going to the ball.
Don't,
I don't by any means think it would be a cake walk,
but a obviously home field advantage will be a huge thing.
So I just figured I'd end the podcast by saying a bunch of obvious shit.
I hope you enjoyed this week's podcast.
Thanks once again to everybody's watching my special and if you haven't watched
it yet,
if he could carve out some time to watch it,
it really helps me because,
uh,
you know,
Netflix is a ratings thing just like any other network.
So if you've already seen it,
thank you so much.
Please tell your friends if you haven't seen any yet,
uh,
and you get a chance,
I know you're busy.
I really appreciate you be helping me out.
Uh,
that's the podcast for this week.
Go fuck yourselves and I will talk to you next Monday.
See you.